JUSTIN JACKSON:
The dream was never
one about mastery
or being a lord.
The dream the entire time
was about sustenance,
about one brother, Joseph,
keeping the others alive.
"And the famine grew
grave in the land.
And it happened when they
had eaten up the provisions
that they had brought to
Egypt that their father said
to them, 'Go back.
Buy us some food.'
And Judah said to him saying,
'The man firmly warned us,
saying 'You shall not see my
face unless your brother is
with you.'"
And of course, in verse
11, Israel relents.
He has to relent.
If it must be so, do it.
And of course, they go back.
They take double the silver.
They bring Benjamin to Joseph,
and they meet Joseph one more
time.
And they explain to him how
they got the silver back
and that they've brought
back even more silver.
And Joseph reassures them,
"'All as well with you.
Do not fear.
Your God and the
God of your father
has placed treasure
for you in your bags.
Your silver has come to me.'
And he brought
Simeon out to them.
And the man brought the
men into Joseph's house.
And he gave them water and
they bathe their feet."
"And they prepared a tribute
against Joseph's arrival
at noon, for they had heard
that they would eat bread.
And Joseph came into the house.
And they brought him the
tribute that was in their hand
into the house.
And they bowed down
to him to the ground."
There's that beautiful
bowing down moment again,
the dream coming to pass.
"And he asked how they were.
And he said, 'Is
it well with your
aged father of whom you spoke?
Is he still alive?'
And they said, 'All is well
with your servant, our father.
He is still alive."
And they bowed
down one more time.
"And he raised his eyes."
And here it is--
"And he saw Benjamin his
brother, his mother's son.
And he says, 'Is this your
youngest brother of whom you
spoke to me?'
And he said, 'God be
gracious to you, my son.'
And Joseph hurried out, for
his feelings for his brother
overwhelmed him and
he wanted to weep,
and he went into the
chamber and wept there.
And he bathed his
face and came out
and he held himself in check.
And he said, 'Serve bread.'"
And this is a stunning moment.
The meal is such a brief
scene, but it's so perfect.
"And they were seated
before him, the firstborn
according to his
birthright, the youngest
according to his youth, and the
men marveled to each other."
And of course, what
they're marveling at here
is that Joseph would
actually know the birth
order, that he can put them
in the correct position.
"And he had portions
passed to them from before,
and Benjamin's portion
was five times more
than the portion
of all the rest."
As if Joseph is reminding
them of the favoritism
that is there with Benjamin.
So yes, everything is right.
All the birth orders in place.
And yet, we see a favor
heaped upon Benjamin here.
And this, of course,
leads us to Chapter 44,
leads us to Joseph's
ultimate plan
to put the goblet
inside of Benjamin's bag
to accuse him of stealing.
He says, "How could we steal
from your master's house silver
or gold?
He of your servants with
whom it be found shall die,
and what's more, we shall
become slaves to our Lord.
And he said, 'Even so, as
by your words, let it be--
he with whom it be found
shall become a slave to me,
and you shall be clear.'"
And they hurried and each man
set down his bag on the ground.
And each opened his bag.
And he searched,
beginning with the oldest
and ending with the youngest.
And he found the goblet
in Benjamin's bag."
Note what Joseph is
going to do here.
He says, "The man in whose
hand the goblet was found,
he shall become my
slave, and you, you
go in peace to your father."
Look at that line.
"You go in peace
to your father."
They know there will
be no peace here
as they go to their father.
And this really is kind
of the stunning moment.
This is Joseph playing off of
the entire history of what they
have done to him, the entire
history of the favoritism
in the family.
Because think about
what they have now.
Their father's beloved
son, Benjamin--
what has he been accused of?
A thief.
Oh, think about
how delicious this
could be going back to Israel.
They could look at him and say,
your beloved son is a thief.
Look at how wrong you
were to favor this thief.
But for some reason,
Judah can't do so.
He gives to Joseph
the back story.
He says, "And your
servant, our father,
said to us, 'You know that
too did my wife bear me.
And one out for
me and I thought,
Oh, he's been torn to shreds.
And I have not seen him since.
And should you
take this one, too,
from my presence
and harm befall him,
you would bring down my gray
head and evil to Sheol.'
And so, should I come to
your servant, my father,
and the lad not be with
us--" this is so important.
"--for his life is
bound to the lad's.
When he saw that the lad was
not with us, he would die.
And your servants
would bring down
the gray head of your
servant, our father,
in sorrow, to Sheol."
"And so, let your
servant, pray, stay
instead of the lad as
a slave to my Lord,
and let the lad go
up with his brothers.
For how shall I go
up to my father,
if the lad not be with us?"
Judah, in this beautiful end to
this penitential narrative, he
who recommended that they
sell Joseph into slavery,
takes slavery on himself.
And he takes slavery on
himself on behalf of one
that he assumes is guilty.
And he sacrifices himself
for really a stunning reason.
And that reason is the
love of his father.
In many ways, I see Judah
as the hero of this story.
What would it take?
Think about the love that
he has for his father
to fear that he would go
down to Sheol mourning.
To be able to swallow
all of that rivalry, all
of the enmity that he
has for his brother,
and all of the favoritism
that his father
has been heaping on Joseph
and Benjamin this entire time.
And Judah is willing to
take all that on and stay
in Benjamin's stead out
of love for his father.
And of course, Joseph sees
that the entire narrative
has been disrupted, that
Judah is broken free,
that the Joseph
story is no longer.
That there is
something new here.
There is a reconciliation, that
the brothers have come around.
In Chapter 45, we get
to see the reunion.
"And Joseph could no longer hold
himself in check before all who
stood in attendance
upon him, and he cried,
'Clear out everyone around me.'
And no man stood with
him when Joseph made
himself known to his brothers.
And he wept aloud, and
the Egyptians heard,
and the house of Pharaoh heard.
And Joseph said to his
brothers, 'I am Joseph.
Is my father still alive?'
But his brothers
could not answer him,
for they were
dismayed before him.
And Joseph said to his brothers,
'Come close to me, pray.'
And they came
close, and he said,
'I am Joseph, your brother
whom you sold into Egypt.
And so now, do not
be pained and do not
be incensed with
yourselves that you sold me
down here, because
for sustenance God
has sent me before you.
Two years now there
has been famine
in the heart of the land.
And there are yet five years
without plowing and harvest.
And God has sent me before you
to make you a remnant on Earth
and to preserve your life for
you to be a great surviving
group."
And now, to bring this
story of the sibling
rivalry to full circle, Joseph
finally reads his dream.
The dream was never one about
mastery or being a lord.
The dream the entire time
was about sustenance,
about one brother, Joseph,
keeping the others alive.
He rejects their dream
of lord and master
and rather offers them
this understanding
of this dream, this dream of
sustenance that Joseph will,
in fact, take care of them.
Joseph the dream
reader now finally
gets to read the dream
of Joseph the dreamer,
the young man who didn't
understand the dreams.
He understands now.
SPEAKER: Thank you for watching.
We hope you're enjoying
our highlight series
and invite you to explore
all of Hillsdale College's
online courses.
They are free and for
everyone who loves to learn.